son las mayores maniobras militares
conjuntas de Estados Unidos y filipinas
de la historia más de 17.000 soldados
participarán en ejercicios por tierra
mar y aire durante las dos próximas
semanas y media y utilizarán por primera
vez artillería real con la que entre
otros objetivos hundirán un viejo barco
filipino de 60 metros estas maniobras
conocidas como balicatán o lo que es lo
mismo hombro con hombro cuenta con casi
tres décadas de historia al principio
eran ejercicios antiterroristas con la
vista puesta en los grupos islamistas
afiliados al caída que atentaban en el
sur del país el objetivo actual aunque
no declarado oficialmente es frenar el
auge de china en la región Beijing ha
criticado estas maniobras apenas Un día
después de haber terminado las suyas en
Taiwán y ha pedido a los dos países que
no interfieran en su integridad
territorial ni en sus derechos marítimos
Beijing y Washington llevan décadas
cortejando a manila para Estados Unidos
es una pieza clave por su cercanía al
mar del sur de China los dos principales
focos de tensión de la zona filipinas
había sido un Aliado tradicional de
Estados Unidos hasta que subió al poder
Rodrigo duterte este comprendió que
necesitaba de las inversiones chinas
para modernizar el país se echó en
brazos de Beijing nunca viajó a
Washington e incluso tuvo un par de
menciones a la madre de Obama muy poco
favorecedoras su sucesor bombón Marcos
es el hijo del dictador durante las
elecciones prometió equidistancia para
no convertirse en un peón geoestratégico
pero Durante los primeros meses ha
mostrado una inclinación muy clara hacia
Estados Unidos a la que incluso ha
permitido abrir cuatro nuevas bases
militares en su territorio